when we talk about the damage that the
anti-vaccine movement does and has done
we usually talk about putting individual
kids at risk or causing localized
breakouts of diseases that may be we
thought we had eradicated or almost
completely eradicated but there's now a
new report that confirms that the
anti-vaccine movements negative effects
are way bigger than a lot of people are
giving them credit for the anti-vaccine
movement has actually undone decades
decades of progress in disease
prevention and it's truly disgusting
this is one of those kooky movements
that is actually really damaging and
threatening to human health flat earther
ism we've talked about flat earther ism
before if you push me I can come up with
some indirect ways in which flat earther
ism connects with other things that are
damaging more broadly but it is sort of
a stretch anti-vaxxer the w-h-o no
longer considers measles eradicated in
the United Kingdom in now Albania the
Czech Republic and Greece which have
also lost their previous Meisel 3 status
and this is because of the anti-vaccine
movement which claims as you know that
measles is just not super serious it's
not that common
most people don't die of it so therefore
it's not necessary to be vaccinated
against measles and of course what they
fail to understand with that they've
might call it logic but it's really the
opposite is that because of vaccines
over the last 50 years measles is not
very prevalent and that is because the
measles vaccine has been so effective
remember that measles used to kill more
than 2 and 1/2 million people per year
in the early 1960s right before the
measles vaccine was introduced and this
has actually happened because this has
gone beyond just people on the internet
repeating the nonsense because you see
even elected officials in some places if
not openly supporting anti-vaxxer
with it or can see
some elements of it like even our
president Donald Trump did during the
2016 Republican primary you may remember
during Republican debates Donald Trump
parroting anti-vaccine points this also
relates to the post truth sort of
element of the Internet age where when
you try to engage with these people and
try to ask the normal questions one
would ask about evidence and all of this
other stuff they'll say listen you know
what in the end your mind is made up and
my mind is made up and somehow those
positions are supposed to be considered
equivalent even though the science is
all on one side they pretend that this
is just a matter of perspective for
example or the freedom to just believe
what you want to believe it is
extraordinarily infuriating and some
incorrectly will say Oh anti-vaxxers are
just really dumb that's all that it's
just these are stupid people lacking
intellectual capacity I don't believe
that this is true at all I think that
anti-vaxxers are likely of average
intelligence - slightly above average
intelligence but they have a combination
of intellectual insecurity combined with
either conspiratorial tendencies and/or
an extreme antipathy towards government
or corporations depending on which side
of the anti-vaccine and it becomes sort
of a perfect storm for getting pulled
down or going down the rabbit hole
combined by the way we're living in a
time where thanks to vaccines there are
way fewer issues with many conditions
which unfortunately just reinforces this
idea that vaccines are not only bad and
harmful but potentially completely
unnecessary and then on the back end
this lends itself to massive propaganda
efforts we talked about how Russian
trolls and these disinformation
campaigns took advantage of trying to
foment racial unrest by using targeted
social media posts in places where there
have been issues like in Ferguson
Missouri or in Baltimore already racial
issues of an often involving police
Russian
trolls have taken advantage of that
Russian trolls are also believed to be
using and spreading anti-vaccination
propaganda in the same way there are
numerous headlines you can find Russian
trolls promoted anti-vaccination
propaganda which may have caused measles
outbreak according to one group of
researchers and believing in this stuff
is in a sense a choice in that it's so
easy to just do a simple google search
and you find authoritative sources that
tell you MMR is not linked to autism
dispelling all of the other myths so it
lends itself to propaganda zation by
adversaries in the exact same way that
Russia has tried and succeeded in
fomenting racial unrest through their
social media campaigns this is really
bad stuff and most of the people in the
movement don't understand the role that
they are playing and the importance of
this in in connecting to so many of
these other movements which I think they
would probably be fighting against if
they understood the interrelatedness so
this is really bad this is not Flat
Earth stuff which has sort of minimal
systemic and broader impacts they are
undoing decades of progress the w-h-o
sees that there are a number of good
reports about it now and unfortunately
it this this you wouldn't think this
being a sort of you know rational
accepting of science a program with an
audience that mostly does the same every
time I talk about this I get very angry
emails from anti-vaccine the audience
who say you're usually right on most
stuff but on this you're just missing
the boat David it's dangerous stuff it
really is